joining us on the line we're honored to
have jim caviezel he's an actress played
jesus christ in mel gibson's the passion
of the christian john reese on cbs's
person of interest most recently doug
rollins in infidel jim thanks so much
for joining the show really appreciate
it
hey thank you ben great to be here so
let's talk about infidel which is
topping the box office
so it is pretty incredible that it's had
the success that it's had
considering that i'm sure the critical
community uh is is not a huge fan of any
movie that points out the persecution of
christians in the middle east
maybe you can talk about the theme of
the movie and uh and why you think it's
so important
well the um really is the
astounding that barbaric christian
persecution is something that's still
going on
today in the 21st century and
really we just want to create a sense of
urgency and relevance to christians and
none
we should be aware and engaged in this
issue
so the basic premise of the movie what
is the movie about for folks who have
not actually seen any of the reviews or
are looking forward to seeing the movie
yeah so in a nutshell i play a
evangelical theologian
who gets invited about by saudi arabia
to speak on his interpretation of jesus
so he goes into uh you know like a talk
show
in saudi arabia and the the
the guy that's doing the interview
says you know we see jesus is
[Music]
wonderful and we love him very much
great and but he's a prophet
and so i'm kind of uh
taught in a really bad situation what am
i going to do and
and um his wife tells him um she's a
very important
uh part of this movie my wife in the
film played by claudia
proven she says you know don't go over
there and profitable the ties don't do
any of that stuff
and essentially christians have been
marginalized all over the world
um iran is growing in christianity
mentally and so this guy says no jesus
is god
that's what we believe in he gets
kidnapped and they need him to deny it
yeah so you know it's movies like this
obviously
you've really acted out your faith in
public not merely in in your own
personal life but also in your career
there's a lot of excitement a lot of
buzz about the uh the potential of doing
a sequel to passion of the christ which
presumably would cover
uh the the resurrection uh can you talk
about the possibility of that arising
what's the plan on that
well it's you know i've been in the
works for probably
you know 10 years but randy wallace who
wrote braveheart with mel gibson um
has been long at work on it and
um i got the and they came out with a
script in 2016.
mel sat on it for a long time and then
he gave his
notes of the direction and then randy
went to
work on it and finally came back
this year which 2020 uh in july
uh the the screenplay and then mel wrote
me
and he said um the script is crazy
which means phenomenal and then he said
um are you ready and i said i was born
ready man
and he said um then uh two months later
i knew that they were gonna you know
they'll be this is the process
then in september 2nd he sent me a
picture
of him holding randy's script now
now it's only two months out from the
second draft so you know it's getting
really close now and i was
extremely you know i'm just like
anything just like with infidel
i'm always scared but i don't get the
easy ones
i didn't choose this path i do believe
in my faith and i do believe that god
chose me for a purpose i mean i
was 19 years old in a movie theater and
i had something come through me that
i was not from this earth and he spoke
to me and said i'd like you to be an
actor and i think
when mel gibson came to me to do
the passion of the christ he was a
little astounded that i said yes and so
immediately
but um i had i felt that this
was what my calling was i mean and again
um if you talk to uh christians they do
feel a calling
because when you take that road it is
the
hard road right so when you look at
uh saul the uh great one um
and he gets knocked off his horse this
is the head pharisee
and he leaves everything to follow
jesus the son of god and he is
persecuted horrifically for his faith
and
not much has changed in 2000 years ben
it still goes on today so when i went
made the movie
the passion of the christ the same
groups
that attacked christians uh came out and
said this is the anti-semitic
uh passion of the christ now let's be
honest here
did mel gibson say anti-semitic things
yes but in his heart
absolutely not because maya morgenstern
who knows the talmud thoroughly and
knows the
uh torah thoroughly um and speaks hebrew
thoroughly an ancient deep hebrew she's
from romania
he loved her um and so
but my job on that was i'm not going to
make a happy jesus here
this is the passion of the christ it's
not the friendship of the christ so
you're going to see
the thorns you're going to see the nails
because this
is what convicts us in places because i
know that you're a jew
and living in a germany during a time at
crystal knot
you had catholics that sat by and did
nothing you had christian evangelicals
doing nothing and then you had catholics
doing something
you have lutherans doing something but
when you sit around
the table at a cafe after what you just
saw during the night
after the night of the broken glass and
you're sitting there saying oh
well you know i personally wouldn't kill
a jew but if you want to you can go
ahead
so where is that happening now when you
see him with the baby
the unborn baby and now the born baby
and so this is about all human uh
all humans that the right to life across
the board and that's
uh what we as christians believe
and there is a time to live on this
earth
but there's also a time to die and there
is no collaboration
all christians need to stand up and
fight back
now jim let's talk about kind of your
your choices as an actor i mean
it's been pretty amazing i i first saw
you on screen in the count of monte
cristo you you
basically move in this very different
direction from
normal movie stardom i mean there's no
question that you were breaking onto the
scene
as an a plus list actor which is why it
was such a shock i think to hollywood's
system when you did passion of the
christ and then when it turned out to be
one of the biggest movies
of all time and what kind of sacrifices
have you had to make
in hollywood in terms of how you've been
treated and and
how you know have scripts disappeared
from you what have your opportunities
been like
in order to to make this contribution to
culture and by the way i think it's an
incredibly important contribution i've
talked
at length about how hollywood undermines
christian and jewish values
undermines judeo-christian values and
and just basic
american values all the time infusing
hollywood with the kind of movies that
you make making a difference in people's
lives and reminding them of biblical
principles an amazingly important thing
i'm sure you must have taken some slings
and arrows for that
yes of course well i mean look
mel came to me my initials are jc and i
was 33 years years
old the exact age that jesus was
crucified when i got that
film so i did believe that i was
uh chosen just as many of us are chosen
to do
certain things and that in the scripture
he says um ask me anything
you know seek ye first the kingdom of
heaven and his righteousness and
everything shall be added to you
but not the way you want things the way
god wants it for you that's
really what our father does he gives you
the things that you need not the things
you want that aren't going to
further you in this journey if i had
gotten the things then that i wanted i
certainly would not be an actor i
certainly wouldn't be
with my wife um i
it's a vocation you know um that was my
calling as an actor and so i couldn't
i'm not a bot and paid for a guy i see
collaborators everywhere in this
in this business film is so important
but let me go let me explain this to you
as far as
what mother teresa talked about a long
time ago
that humility comes from humiliation
so you got to get in a shot you got to
get in the turd you got to smell the
manure
right this is this is rough it's not
easy
but i go to my farm and i
take the rocks out and i i have to get
the soil ready
and it's rough it's hard but eventually
you know
when i ask god in my prayers please give
me some but not too much you'll kill my
crops
please you know give me rain but not too
much you flood them and kill them
so that's the the the how uh
i act is is um how it comes through me
and it's not just a mental
physical thing it's also a spiritual
thing and that spiritual always
brings me back to jesus and through my
mother mary who i love so much and
and she gives me an understanding in
this business because there's a lot of
temptations right
guys ask me this all the time but i'm
not a dog
right so i i know that that this is
really important and i
looked at charlton heston you know when
he played moses
and ben hur and he really tried to be a
a really decent guy and tried to
live the the the right life and
and and and he took it to the screen so
be that person
and then act that way um and so
uh count of monte cristo the film that
came and they um rewrote this script and
and they took uh mentions of god out of
it god will give me justice
and i said look you can't take god out
of this
book it's in in one of the comments was
though so you're one of those and i said
one of those what one of those that
rewrites shakespeare or rewrites
alexander dumas
this is guys this is what people the
the deplorables okay who we are
we are people that um love uh god
as our father and and know that he
deserves to be loved
and we want to freely do that in moving
infidel when you have people putting a
gun to your head like a theocracy
and forcing religion into you so we
don't want that
here and we don't want uh secular
extremists
um forcing that uh on us as well and
telling us who
and what our faith is and what if we can
go to church or not and that's again
happening here this is part of also then
the persecutions that we're going
to going through right now and why
people need to go see
infidel because they're being persecuted
out there well heck they're doing it
right here
and if we're ever going to go to war we
should go to war with secular extremists
that is a war that needs to be fought
and must be
won now so christians need to start
speaking the truth
well jim caviezel the movie is infidel
definitely go check it out it's also
directed by cyrus naraste who's a
personal friend and an incredible talent
uh jim congratulations on the film
congratulations also on the filming of
the sequel to passion of the christ
which i'm sure will be just as enormous
ahead and just as impactful culturally
thanks for what you do really appreciate
it
ben thank you to your wonderful man